peut-être que le retard est certainement difficile à
cerner, difficile à décrire, c'est pourquoi je l'
aime bien. J'aime ce personnage
Amber Heard qui joue essentiellement le
rôle de la femme fatale. Il y a quelque chose
d'inhumain chez elle que j'aime.
que la vie, elle établit ses propres règles,
vous ne pouvez pas demander une meilleure plate-forme oui,
en tant qu'acteur, vous espérez
quelque chose comme ça de temps en temps, c'est
vraiment amusant,
c'est une professionnelle qui a trouvé une place dans une
organisation qui, alors qu'elle opère dans
un  façon très inhabituelle dont nous avons besoin pour venir travailler
pour moi en échange de vos
services de nettoyage je pourrais vous offrir un
médicament expérimental
et elle est très mise au défi dans ce film
parce que kevin est une si forte
présence à l'écran donc je suis arrivé à ambre tôt et j'ai
dit que tu devais  être très forte donc nous avons
vraiment pris ce défi au sérieux et
elle est très crédible et elle s'est préparée
très intensément et nous savons tous que c'est une
jolie fille mais je ne voulais pas qu'elle
dépende d'elle pour être jolie
sortez-la de situations difficiles et bon je
voulais qu'elle soit intelligente et
puissante c'est un personnage très coloré
et je pense qu'elle a très bien réussi avec
ces questions tuer ou mourir c'est
impossible à expliquer
tu penses que papa va rester aussi
longtemps qu'il le peut ma chérie